um
representative Sullivan if you want to
Sure address this
yeah let's do the Pledge of Allegiance
first okay
first sentence first
I pledge allegiance to get to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
it's
you know what I'm gonna move over here
so I can see everybody that that would
be better
so in in communication with
representative Vale
um the uh she has put together an
amendment that is identical to the last
version we saw with the exception of uh
lines 15 and 16.
which are a couple of other
exclusions this section shall not apply
to employees of Emergency Medical
Service law enforcement Public Safety
officials and firefighting service so uh
it um
it seemed to her and I agreed with her
that
excluding these folks from this was
appropriate and um
and that they were not covered by the uh
either 126x or the section
two that refers to federal law
regulations so
um
with uh
with that change
um
you know we've got a little bit uh
narrower scope on on who's covered by
this and uh excuse me
I'm uh
I I also drawn to the uh testimony that
Michael
um uh
trying to remember yes Mike Holt
um Gabe that this this is a relatively
small number of folks that that are
impacted by this and you know by having
some exclusions the group gets
potentially even smaller I'm not really
sure if these exclusions actually not
touching anybody oh they're speak of the
um but uh at any rate uh
there's a copy of the uh there you go
no 15 and 16s are added
right the old 15 and 16 would be
something different
exactly
just bumped it down
foreign
[Music]
we do have uh David Jewett here from uh
business and industry Association I'd
like to
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Dave Juve I'm a senior vice
president for public policy with the
business and industry Association I
guess I would like to preface my remarks
so the subcommittee understands the Bia
did not take a position on this bill I
was at the public hearing and thought
the the testimony was profound
um we did not testify we did not sign in
with a position and we're about as close
to neutral is an organization like mine
would be so I hope you'll take my
comments in that Spirit
um
my concern is that uh
this bill
could have
unforeseen uh consequences for some
employers and
if I were to make a request of the
subcommittee and the committee
it would be to retain this bill because
um
as with representative Cahill's bill on
on uh paid time off I think there's a
kernel of a good idea here that deserves
full consideration
and if the committee were disposed to
retaining the bill
we would offer up the expertise of our
employment attorneys to work with the
committee
um in in a
proactive way not not to to kill the
bill but to try and come up with a bill
that everybody
thinks would work best
[Music]
um
you know what what I do for a living is
I have to look at the politics of a
situation and
if the committee votes on this bill even
with this clarifying Amendment
if it comes out with a 10 to 10 without
recommendation and goes to the house
floor that way it's anybody's guess what
would happen
and frankly I think it would be
unfortunate if the bill were to be itl'd
on on the house floor because then you
have to start all over again whereas if
you retain a bill and everyone works
cooperatively on it obviously you don't
have to start from scratch
if it were to pass the house
my observation is it would have a real
uphill fight in the Senate
and would possibly be a bill that the
governor would consider consider vetoing
obviously that's all speculation but I
guess
if it were me I'd like to err on the
side of safety and and have the bill
retained so we can all work on it and
then cooperatively come forward in
January of next year with something that
everybody agrees is workable just one
last comment on on the amendment which
thank you representative Sullivan I just
saw it and I understand the um
point that has been made on lines 15 and
16 but again it raises questions because
there are a lot of other types of
employment that could have impact on the
public like school bus drivers or
cab drivers or snow plow drivers
I could probably go on and on but my
point is
if we're carving out this exemption for
these types of employment
shouldn't other types of employment that
could impact Public Safety also be
considered and that's an example of
why I think if we if we
didn't feel like we were in a rush to to
try and get this through this session
with all the risks that that involves
maybe if if everybody sits down
including really smart attorneys who
represent employers
perhaps we can come up with something
good and I will tell you I sent out
recently
um
an email to to the employer
either HR
managers VPS and employment attorneys
asking their opinion on the bill because
I have to tell you it first blush the
bill which is a relatively simple one is
not one that left me with a lot of angst
and the responses I got back which I
would like to forward to all of you so
you can see a more interesting because
they ran the gamut from some HR managers
who acknowledged look
this is an issue we're going to have to
deal with in one form or another
eventually
to another attorney who suggested well
there's a recent New Hampshire uh
Supreme Court case that acknowledged
that
cannabis for medical use could be part
of a reasonable accommodation on the
part of employers to a third attorney
that said you know the devil's kind of
in the detail so my point is
I guess this Echoes why we didn't have a
strong position one way or the other
even with HR professionals representing
employers there there are positions all
over the Spectrum on this bill so that
can I I don't know if that's helpful I'd
be happy to try and answer any questions
but those are my thoughts
thank you sir any questions
representative Sullivan
I think one of the things that we did at
our last meeting
and I've done quite a bit since is look
very carefully at section 126 x colon 3
of the rsas and that is the prohibitions
and limitations on the therapeutic use
of cannabis so
when you look at this
with this
it
I think it would it should relieve
anything not I won't say it will relieve
all anxiety because we're all a little
anxious
um but it should relieve
a lot of anxiety
um
because uh essentially
and I might lean on Michael hold a
little bit here
um because we've spent a fair bit of
time talking about the difference
between Under the Influence versus
um
impaired right and arguably somebody
with THC in their system
well I know I think you're you're not
under the influence long
um long before THC flushes out of the
yeah but at the same time
someone who's using therapeutic cannabis
um at some point when it's taking taking
its therapeutic course one is
Under the Influence but they are not
um intended to be impaired
um the the objective is
deal with the
um symptoms
but stay short of impairment
um
but
um says that nothing this chapter shall
exempt any person from arrest or
prosecution for operating a motor
vehicle commercial vehicle boat vessel
or any other vehicle propelled or drawn
by power other than muscular power
thank you
um so we're talking about cab drivers
and um that type of thing they're
already addressed under um 126 X3
um
when it comes to other types of
employment operating heavy machinery or
handling dangerous instrumentality
so people on the job who are you know at
a heightened level of safety concern
certainly are excluded from
um
being in the in or are not protected by
the the bill by itself leaves a lot of
unanswered questions the bill in
combination with 126 X3 I believe leaves
far far far fewer questions
um so um I would argue that this um
I mean if you if you ask people
um
cold
whether they'd have any concerns just
reading this
um they probably will if they are given
an opportunity to carefully study the
126x3 along with the bill
um I think they should have a lot of
their concerns alleviated
that's possible I I will admit I only
sent out the original language of the
bill because frankly I didn't know that
the amendment existed and this is our
Second Amendment so
um yeah it it it's tightened it up
substantially
um and um I I think we've been working
on it and um you know these these folks
need protection as you pointed out there
is a Supreme Court case that protects
um someone's rights to uh accommodation
um unfortunately their protection comes
to the courts which is a pretty painful
way of getting there if you are of
limited means
um you can't afford the lawyers that are
going to get you uh
um your resolution so it it it's a
relatively small group of people who are
on the program and employed
um and there are a lot of folks who are
um
who are already separated out either
through what's in the bill
or through what's
in the original uh statute yeah
I'm not arguing with any of that and
again I want to stress I'm not here
opposing the bill I hear you um I'm here
to offer our resources if the committee
would like to
um
improve it and maybe it's been improved
to the extent that it could be I don't
know because I you know I'd like to send
the amended language out this afternoon
and get some comments on that and I
guess when you started your testimony my
original thinking was what exactly needs
to be improved and I am I correct that
we don't you don't presently have an
answer to that
they're not that I'm comfortable
expressing to the subcommittee what I am
comfortable in doing is sending you the
unedited
emails that I got back and you'll see
that they're all over the map and then
you could make a decision on your own
whether the amendment has addressed
those concerns or not I think that'd be
great to have
sure
thanks thanks for taking my question so
on the Second Amendment I'm um I'm still
having a problem with the the no
employer shall deny employment I was
hoping that that was going to be removed
from this amendment because I I feel
strongly that we should not be
legislating at that level they should be
able to make a decision based off of
their circumstances and when I reached
out to the employers that
um I have in the my district
um
with the exception of one who was
perfectly fine with smoking marijuana
and things that should be legal
everybody else was against this bill and
asked me to continue to oppose it
um so as long as that denying employment
is in there I'm not going to be in favor
of this
um and the further thing that I thought
about after leaving here at the last
session and talking with somebody else I
reflected a lot on
this whole the the the uh
advocating that people will not be
taking this while they're at work that
they know better that they can't take
this while they're at work
and what was said was if these people
are so uncomfortable or in so much pain
or having trouble dealing with whatever
their issue is that they need to be on
cannabis
then how is it that they can get through
a 10 or an eight hour shift without
being on cannabis but they can't make it
through the night before or the day
before or the weekend
um and you know that made a lot of sense
to me so how is it that they can manage
to carve out a 10-hour part of their day
where they have no pain and no issue
that they don't need to to medicate
themselves I find that hard to accept I
think that they are so um as much as the
law says they shouldn't be and as much
as it's written that they shouldn't be
in action can be taken I think that it's
very naive of us to think that canvas
users who have a card who are taking it
for pain management or for
um anxiety or other mental health issues
I think it's naive us to think that
they're not taking that during the day
when they're at work
is that so Sullivan
I had a feeling that you might still be
a have concerns about the hiring issue
and um
I gave a lot of thought to that between
then and now and concluded especially
after looking looking and thinking about
other
um uh
uh issues of discrimination
basically discrimination
protections
always include hiring and on the job
if you find out that someone that you
just made a job offer to has a
disability
that doesn't stop them from doing the
job but might require an accommodation
you can't just decide not to hire them
anymore
that's standard discrimination policy so
um I reached the point where for me I
know where you're at I understand it I
respect it but
for me you I can't
accept having this
anti-discrimination
bill be different from any every other
form of discrimination where
um
you can't discriminate if they're
already on the job but you can
discriminate if it's in the middle of
the hiring process so uh to me that's
that's a
um a showstopper
um and and to address the other piece
in reality
um
126 X3 does allow
someone to use
cannabis on the job as long as you have
the written permission of your employer
without that you can't
um and um you can have it on on the job
site with the written permission of your
employer if you don't get that written
permission you can't have it on the site
and there are two two different written
permissions one to to be under the
influence the other two
um
to actually have it on the job site so
number one you can and number two with
regard to those who use it at night
um I I can just give you my personal
situation without going into gory
details
um but basically when I got the card
which is expired by the way it's it's it
it was yeah it was kind of cool to have
but the um I'll keep in my wallet for
another 10 years
um but um
my issue is sleeping at night the
symptoms I had that I got the card for I
still have those symptoms
um
last night was not good I was in the
recliner all night
um and I wish I had something that could
have resolved it right now I'm here do I
have symptoms yes but they're not as bad
when I'm awake
I don't think I'm alone with that I
think others share that situation and
essentially really need help sleeping
and that was a situation I was in
um and by God hopefully not too much
longer but I'm still in it so it that
that really does exist and people who
have symptoms that need to be resolved
during the night so they can get a good
night's sleep
um it it's a real thing so um I'll just
put that out there
everything called
I'd like to follow up on the reasonable
accommodation the reasonable
accommodation is unless the employer can
demonstrate that the accommodation would
impose an undue hardship on the
operation of its business and when
you're looking at electricians and crane
operators and HVAC technicians and a lot
of the trades I would argue that making
an accommodation for cannabis use would
be an undue hardship based off of just
the the SEC the safety needs that are
that are needed in those jobs and in
those trades so
um I'm I'm sorry to disappoint I I don't
disagree with Dave as far as retaining
this because the deny employment is a
hard stop for me I you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna vote against this and I will
Advocate against this because of the
denying employment I just don't think we
should be putting those types of
handcuffs on our employers and and I
guess I would argue that you're right
about the accommodations
um if and basically it's already in
yeah
I I thought it sounded good uh the
um but basically it's already in 126a I
haven't I read it short while ago if I
can find it again
um
the sausage operating heavy machinery or
handling and dangerous instrumentality
so essentially you know those employers
employees who are um
in those situations
um can be excluded from this
um so I I I I think that piece is not a
concern for me the hiring is not a
concern for you it is I get it but um
I would hope that we could narrow our
thank you I've got I've got my my
concerns still uh you know we we have
two lines here with the the to uh exempt
employee different employment
I'm guessing I could probably add
another 75 lines to it
um you know uh I I go back to Justice
Scalia saying the the Constitution says
what it says and it doesn't say what it
doesn't say this bill says what it says
and it doesn't say what it doesn't say
and those the the things uh
representative cocom just outlined uh
this this dozens more uh I could go as
far as uh somebody sitting at a computer
that and making a you know a very very
Hefty Financial mistake
um you know the the employer has no has
no recourse uh you know uh I don't think
we can't go there uh
you know we we argued about
um about uh you know people on this in
this program a lot of them wouldn't
take advantage of it
but a lot of them would too
you know um but I don't I don't want to
say you know I have this card you can't
do a Don thing to me
um you know I don't I don't think we we
should be doing that to employers
and um you know I'm I'm still I made
that motion to retain this needs an
awful lot of work it um
you know like I said we we could add 75
more lines of uh of occupations that uh
should be exempt
um you know I've I've got a friend that
uh I saw him the other night he lost his
arm he was uh doing a siding job he was
his own employer okay I won't work with
this guy because uh he does everything
to Don fast okay their absent-minded
ADHD all that kind of stuff but that's
kind of the symptoms that a somebody
that just smoked a jointed have the
and he put up some some staging and uh
some pump staging I don't know if
anybody's familiar with it but you know
it's good arms that uh that connected to
the building well he missed a stud and
he put a bolt through some OSB that the
the follow particle board
and he goes up on the stage and a tour
off the wall and he came down and he
didn't you know he he broke his arm but
he ended up losing the arm but I don't
want that you know if he was an employee
okay and and there's you know three or
four guys on a on a on a crew and one of
them smoked a joint for lunch you know
and he's got this card uh and he missed
the he missed the stud and just put it
into the OSB like Tommy did uh you know
where does that leave the employer
you know uh it's we're going we're
opening up a nasty can of worms here I
think that I spoke with the the
insurance commissioner's office uh a
lawyer there uh but uh you know he said
the the insurance commission's office
had no no position on it but he and I
spoke of this type of stuff and uh you
know this needs an awful lot of work I
guess for me until we until we can tell
whether you
you know smoked a joint last night
but you know three and a half minutes
before you punched in uh you know we're
gonna have trouble
um I I don't want to see any employer a
small businessman uh losing his home
over it you know and I I can see the
ugliness of that coming up
you know another another quote that I I
like is Lyndon Baines Johnson
you know when considering legislation we
not only have to look at all the good
it'll do if it's implemented rightly but
more importantly all the bad it'll do if
it's implemented wrongly and this just
this this just has all kinds of holes to
implement it wrongly
representative thank you Mr chairman
I'm going to look at a different way
um I think we have
when I was reading this information I
think there's 25 states that do it
um
so they they're able to figure it out I
think the last bill we had and last time
this bill came in I think what we tried
doing really wanted to build down too
much was to have all these carbots
but I go back to this whole thing and
I'm you know because it just seems like
and I respect everybody's opinion but we
seem to get fixated on this whole thing
of you know whether they're going to do
it before work whether they're going to
do it you know at night and I'll tell
you right now
um
from someone that you want to talk about
sleep deprivation where can the fire
service for 30 years and somebody told
me when the day I retired that my sleep
was going to get better well it's been
almost seven years and I can guarantee
you that my sleep is no better
um
so
if sleep deprivation was part of the
therapeutic cannabis program I think I'd
probably be a card holding member
but on the other
on the other side I mean I look at and
what my
representative colcum was talking about
and I understand you know we don't know
um
if somebody's using at night or
somebody's using it during the day but I
think we can say the same thing about
opioids and I think again if we go back
to these opioids I think a lot of times
that people are trying to get what
getting on the therapeutic cannabis
program is to get away from the opioids
but we don't test somebody at work
to my knowledge for the use of opioids
they do
in any accident
any industrial accident and in
occupations that I've been involved in
with it I won't say any so and I'm gonna
I will say this
because there is a way that they can
test to see how much cannabis is in your
system because I've had a discussion uh
with a very good friend of mine and it
would come from a blood draw
the reality of it is I think that's very
difficult to get but in the case of an
accident an incident that may have
harmed somebody at work
I don't think it'd be treated any
differently than a DWI that hurts
somebody so if they really wanted to get
down to the nuts and bolts of it and
find out if that person was impaired
there is a way they can do it and they
can find out and yeah it's going to work
but again it's no different than it's no
different than the DWI where somebody's
going to get hurt so
um
I like the bill do I think there's some
things that we could work on I do but
again my belief is if 25 States in this
country have done it and we don't see it
it's not exploding on the TV every night
I'm not watching TV and saying you know
oh Rhode Island had this massive you
know accident at work incident because
somebody was smoking cannabis I I don't
see it I just I don't see it happening
so I don't really think it's creating a
big issue but I respect everybody's
opinion and respect you know and I would
definitely encourage us to continue
working on this because I do think this
is something that
um we should move forward
thank you when I uh when I was speaking
to the uh the insurance commissioner's
office lawyer there uh you know we
talked about the the other states that
have it and everything and uh he said
it's he figured it was only a matter of
time before you know whether it's a a
you know a workers comp case or or just
um you know liability cases it's only a
matter of time before all those things
start rearing their ugly head uh
I think we need to work on this and
representative Sullivan
um
I guess I'd like to make a couple
suggestions
um I did talk with uh chairman infantine
at length last night and um
I think he and I agree that if the bill
is going to be retained we'd rather do
that with the full committee rather than
here
um and I guess what I'd like to make
sure we do here is if we as a
subcommittee feel that this amendment is
an improvement over a the original Bill
and B the um uh the earlier amendment I
would suggest that we adopt the
amendment or recommend adoption of the
amendment so we're moving
we know what to look at when we get back
to the committee I don't think we want
to be looking at the original bill
because I think the sponsors didn't feel
like the original bill was well crafted
so I would hate to be back at that point
because I I would argue and I'd hope
folks could agree that this amendment is
better and this happens sometimes I've
done it I voted I think we've done it as
a committee this year we voted in favor
of an amendment that improves a bill
than people in the vote on
ought to pass is amended may vote
against that as a resolution so
um I would suggest Mr chairman that may
maybe we take up the amendment in terms
of whether or not this is Improvement
I did hear representative Holcomb and I
think I was clear with my view on the
hiring aspect
um
I believe you would prefer something
that didn't include hiring I can't
accept something that excludes hiring so
that's I think where we are with the
subcommittee
um and um
uh
unless both of my other colleagues feel
one way or the other unanimously and I
suspect that's not the case
um but I can I only get one vote
um so
um my suggestion is to take up the
amendment
no it's always been my understanding
that a subcommittee like this is uh only
uh suggestive you know recommendation
and uh you know I
I see the amendment is better but still
far from what we need and uh you know we
can certainly bring this this amendment
to the to the full committee and uh you
know use this as part of the uh you know
the the the the motion to retain but uh
you know have this as part of the uh the
the thing we're going to work with
um
you know but uh I'd still uh like to
entertain a motion to to retain
and um you know as far as a
yeah
I'll make a motion that we retain uh
Hospital 82
with the Second Amendment
um back to the committee
as a matter of procedure you can't
retain
um
with uh the amendment the amendment has
to be
um adopted
so if we're retaining we'd be retaining
I'll make a motion that we retain House
Bill 82
I vote does not carry
um and um
I guess I would make a motion to adopt
the amendment
um as presented
and again I would encourage the
committee to just consider that we're
upgrading the bill to a better form
perhaps not a perfect form
um so um
about now
representative Susie yes
representative Sullivan I vote Yes and
um
I guess we're going back to committee uh
with a hung jury and
I could I think that's fine we can um
we've got an exact session next week and
we can um work it out there I
I would argue
I'm arguing again
um
um that we've not wasted our time I
think we've had uh
um
lots of discussion I think um we have
made progress
um and um I would you know be intend to
bring this amendment to the uh the full
committee
um and see where it lands but um
and and we'll see where it goes I it
will not be the end of the world if it
gets retained
are looking to maintain an employed
status without the threat of um
of termination or discipline I think
this is important today not uh a year
from now so that's that's why I feel
that moving forward would be a good
thing and I firmly believe that the
amendment
along with
um
um RSA 126x3 in combination
um do a good job of
getting us as close as we can to where
we need to be I also suggest Mr javet
that if you can send that information to
us that would be terrific
thank you Mr chairman make a quick
comment yes um yeah I will do that
representative Sullivan I'll uh send it
to all four of you and copy chairman
infantine on it just so he's aware of it
and I will also send out the language of
the amendment and ask for comments on
that and see if that changes uh people's
opinion but you'll see when you get the
emails there were some of our members
who didn't have a problem with the bill
somewhere on the fence and some thought
it could create problems
thank you
just one question would the other
members of the committee here the uh
willing to uh to amend the amendment I
guess uh on lines 15 and 16 uh to
something uh
or any any occupation uh that uh or any
anything that would uh put the the life
and safety uh of of others at risk
um
you know put something in there for for
uh
you know maybe Financial
um
who to me we've got to expand those
those two lines I I guess I would um
look back to the original
um bill as introduced
um
it has a line in there that says this
section shall not apply to employment or
drug screening tests are required for
the safety of persons and property at
the job site
um
it was
concluded at the outset that that
language which is somewhat similar to
what you just suggested is so vague and
so broad that it would exclude virtually
everyone
um so um we were immediately asked not
to act on
the bill is introduced and I think
that's what we're we're at risk of if we
use General language
um
an employer could say everyone is
excluded no one on our job site can
um be part of the program
um if um if we use specific language and
say this list of 75
job descriptions
um
uh are excluded
so
the 76th will come in and there will be
an issue because it's assumed that if
you have an exhaustive list of uh
employment that is excluded that
everything else is included
um and there's uh a lot of risk in doing
that so I think we want to avoid
extremely broad language or extremely
specific language so the bill is
and and and I would again point out that
a lot of employment types are already
Exempted
um
by the uh by the bill I would encourage
everyone to read that and it and I would
acknowledge that 126 X3
is um
difficult to read
the fact that there's no indentations
makes it hard to figure out where one
section begins the next one begin
um
um and so so it it it is difficult to
read but if you read it carefully there
are a lot a lot of types of employment
that are already
excluded so um
that's really important to uh to look at
because we don't have to read in fact
frankly
um in talking to the sponsor yesterday
there was an urge to repeat something
that's already in 126 X3 I think that's
a big mistake because if you say it one
way in one section of the law and
another way in another section of law
you don't know which one takes the
precedent so um you know to repeat
what's in already in the statute for the
purpose of uh
emphasis is a bad idea basically we've
got 126 X3 and we've got uh the bill
that's before us and the two should not
overlap we should be careful about that
see my problem is uh you know a lot of
industrial accidents happen in the
construction trades yeah we haven't even
mentioned them
uh you know I'm sure they are not
specifically construction but again
operating heavy machinery that's happens
in construction or handling a dangerous
instrumentality
um that's all kinds of
um uh
uh two tools on the job site that could
um
liability
does it say that
you know we're we're in section three it
specifically says it's referring to
employment
so just because somebody's arrested or
prosecuted
doesn't mean that they're necessarily
going to lose their job over this but
so there's so many holes on this that
we need to retain it and work on it and
close those holes
we feel that some positions are more
sensitive than others that they would be
excluded
you know why why do we feel that other
positions are not worthy of being
excluded permits because essentially the
employer is required to make
accommodation
um the requirement requirement to make
an accommodation if if you're a truck
driver
um
you can't accommodate that um
however if you are
um uh on the construction job site lots
of accommodations can be made to avoid
certain types of uh activities so
um because as I said someone who's got a
shovel in his hand and digging a hole is
not
um uh in need of accommodation and
someone who is running a
dangerous powered equipment might be
reassigned to the shovel rather than the
dangerous uh equipment so you know those
are the types of accommodations that
employers can make
um
it's it's a bit of a pain it's a
nuisance it's an inconvenience but
that's what our non-dis um
anti-discrimination
um uh laws do
um they protect people and let them stay
on the job with reasonable reasonable
accommodations
and would we run into the problem of an
excavator operator uh making 75 dollars
an hour reduced to a guy shoveling
that's making 17 an hour and uh you know
that there's another can of worms that
those are issues that need to be
resolved sure
well I I could see the excavator
operator that can no longer operate that
still wanting his 75 dollars an hour and
and try to try and litigate that or go
through a union union repunion uh
agreements
um
go ahead I'm sorry we're pretty informal
you've got a basis you know what that
employee
you know you know what their performance
is like you can have something to
measure number
when you're being forced to hire
somebody
when it's against your local policy and
your practices because we have to now
Force this law down their throat that
they must fire if they can't find a
reasonable accommodation or a reason why
they are excluded for the reasonable
Foundation
they have no basis they're going on on
the interview process which is typically
a few hours talking to you know a few
people a few hours in in somebody's
selling themselves up we all know a very
difficulty you make it and not every job
can be a vacancy and make a type of job
and I just don't think we should be
you know if there's personal
responsibility in this and if if I have
a cannabis card and I have to take
cannabis for whatever the reason I have
a personal responsibility and my
responsibility is also to keep my job
and ownership is on me I should not be
expecting the employer to be forced to
keep me and I don't think we should
expect any employer to be divorced to
keep somebody it's personal
responsibility we have you know we can't
legislate away from personal
responsibility
but again and I'll go back to this
there's nothing saying because somebody
has therapeutic cannabis card that
they're going to be
Under the Influence or impaired at work
if somebody goes for an interview right
somebody goes for an interview and we I
think we had discussion
and
they were the best candidate
they were the best candidate by far and
because they all of a sudden take out
I have a problem with that because if
they were overall they obviously had the
ability to go in and I think somebody
that
I truly believe that if somebody has to
do gummies if they have to smoke
marijuana if it has to be all the time
they're not going to be able to go
through a interview and be the best
candidate if they have to be on this
stuff all the time
so I think it's I understand what you're
saying but I think I mean
I'd like to see how much is happening
right now I mean dick it could be going
on right now just because we want to
bring this law forward
now it's becoming a problem I can
guarantee it's probably happened in the
workplace right now and we don't know
about it and
so I I don't really think it's a bad
thing I think it's it's trying to get
people back to work
um and again they're not gonna they will
be there'll be carve outs but I just
think that
um
I think it's not giving these people a
fair shot at employment
um
especially if they come out and they're
the top candidate I just don't believe
that somebody that may have eaten a five
milligram gummy at night is going to be
affected the next morning an interview
so
it may be that the employer still
chooses to hire that person right so I
I'm not saying that by taking this out
the employer is automatically not going
to there are going to be some employers
who won't because that's their policy
um and it may be because their worker
comp claims it could be for a lot of
reasons it could just be the nature of
the work
but leaving it up to their decision
is where I think it needs to be I I
don't disagree with you I think that
there's a population of people who
um are not affected at work to the
extent of what maybe we want to over
dramatize it to be but um
I think the employer should be given the
free will to make that decision on their
own to move forward or not and if they
are an outstanding candidate and and
they want to move forward with that then
yeah I failed to mention that I had a
about an hour long conversation with a
union organizer that I know and uh you
know he was bringing up a lot of a lot
of the same stuff that we've been
talking here but
you know he kind of concurred that this
is a this is a can of worms that needs
to be worked on and uh you know it could
cause a lot of problems for unions can
cause a lot of problems for employers
workers comp companies just regular
liability insurance companies uh you
know this this is uh this is this says
tentacles you know far reach and
tentacles I guess you could say and um
you know we've uh
we've got to tighten this thing up
before before we presented as something
is that it yeah motion to adjourn
anybody I would just see Mr Juve are you
aware that the exact session is the 15th
okay
yep